-"SNL" 40th --
they used all our dressing rooms
for fancy people.
Taylor Swift was in here,
and she very sweetly
left a thank-you note,
and I was like,
"Yeah, this is my life now."
Which I still do
all the time.
But mostly my life is, like,
picking up my dog [bleep]
and stuff like that,
you know.
♪♪
-In my first season,
I shared a dressing room
with Kate and Cecily.
We were right next to
the women's restroom,
which I always thought
was a big win,
'cause I'm a dumper.
Let's see. Is this going good?
[ Laughs ] Um...
Our first year, I do feel like
our dressing room kind of became
like the hub
for all the new cast
and new writers, so, like,
Timmy Robinson and Chris Kelly
and Sarah Schneider.
You know, I mean, like,
it's also like, you're in there
for hours and hours
at a time,
especially in your
first seasons
'cause you're not in that much.
It is, like, where
the three of us really bonded,
which is very nice.
My second season, Cecily and I
shared a dressing room,
and then the following season
I got
the beautiful digs
that I'm in now.
You know, no windows.
They actually just redid
the carpet.
Gave us new couches 'cause they
were eaten by moths.
So I'm living the high life.
You know, we're in these rooms,
like, all the time.
I've tried to just surround
myself with little things
that just, like, make me happy.
Almost everything in here
is like some little
reminder of a person
either I worked with
or something that someone
gave to me.
So this does become like
my home three days of the week.
I have a framed photo
that Colin gave me
that is my husband I giving the
finger in the back of a taxi.
I really like that one.
Truly, like, some of my darkest
times have happened in here,
which is why I have so many,
like, lotions and potions
for, like, camouflaging.
But it's like, you know,
we work these insane hours.
At the end of it you still
have to come back here usually
and keep going, and so
I mostly use this space
to, like, recoup in some way.
-Featuring Aidy Bryant.
-My first season,
I hosted a presidential debate,
and it was maybe like
my fifth show ever.
It was this weird scenario where
I couldn't have cue cards
in front of me.
They had cue cards guys
dressed up as extras,
and then they would pop up
a single card
and then pop it back down.
And I was so nervous.
I remember just over
and over again
in my dressing room going, like,
"Good evening.
Good evening."
Full psycho.
Couldn't stop practicing that
'cause I was so nervous.
I still, to this day,
am, like, haunted by that
first line where I'm like,
"Good evening from
Hofstra University
in Hempstead, New York."
Right before air, a note was
sent down, I think from Lorne,
that they were like,
"She looks too young.
Add age makeup."
So they were literally
counting down like,
"5, 4, 3..."
The makeup artist was, like,
desperately trying to put,
like, shadow under my eyes
and stuff.
He didn't mean to, but he
poked me in the eye.
And they were like,
"3, 2, 1."
[ Laughter ]
Good evening from
Hofstra University
in Hempstead, New York.
I'm Candy Crowley from
CNN's "State of the Union."
[ Applause ]
But it worked out okay,
and, like, I got to say
"Live from New York" --
the very first time I ever
got to say "Live from New York."
Thank you, and live from
New York, it's "Saturday Night"!
Tom Hanks was also
in the sketch, and Bill Hader,
and they both, like,
came on either side of me
and, like, ran me down the hall,
and all the hair and makeup
and costumes people
were there, and they
clapped for me,
and it was, like, one of
the coolest moments
I've ever had here.
I think of my office as, like,
a place for collaboration
and people to come by and us
to, like, write together,
and I think of this as, like,
a much more quiet space.
If people come in here,
it's usually to, like,
talk about how nervous we are.
-..."Saturday Night"!
-Every time a sketch ends,
you have to run
and someone's pulling
your pants down
and you're ripping
your shirt off,
and this is like one of
the few places
that we get to, like,
find a little quiet,
and I think it's nice
to have a nice little cozy home.
♪ And that's what I have here ♪
[ Laughs ]